jordan montgomery comes in with a record
of four and five
somewhat misleading he's allowed only
one run in his last 19 and two-thirds
innings of work
lack of run support for sure last eight
starts just got 18 runs to work with
the 01 pitch to hunter renfro
laced into left and it drops for the
game's first hit
and once again that's the fastball
middle of the zone be ready to hit it
that's the fourth seamer jordan will
kind of throw almost as many four
seamers as two seamers before semer up
and zander just missed it was on time
just a little bit underneath it now to
the change up
and he got him
and you called it
well it's a classic combination right
rolls it toward the hole
they've got the shift on do they have a
plane no he beats it out and look at
this renfro is sprinting for third
and he's out
velasquez was running the post pattern
to go cover third he was
and the pass was right on target
well this is some play which i guess
we'll get another look at right now
that's a heads-up play by voight
and by velasquez to get there cover the
base just in time
after half an ending no score
the numbers on tanner hauck and the one
loss record belies the fact that he's
generally pitched well and he has elite
stuff
the strike one pitch to judge
devers has three chances in the inning
handles them all flawlessly and down go
the yankees in order
jd martinez starts it for the red sox at
293 with 23 home
runs and he strikes out on three pitches
i mean some people just have their
pitchers that they cannot solve he
clearly is not seeing the ball out of
jordan's hand and he's seen him a lot as
i mentioned one for 15. d.h today
did he go around he did
but sanchez has to recover the ball to
throw him out and he can't do it
so a strikeout but schwarber reaches
well kyle did not react immediately
to the possibility of running the first
but sanchez couldn't find the ball
immediately
he's out
jerry meals the play-doh player is the
crew chief
montgomery coming right over the top as
tom noted
vasquez says a fly ball into the shallow
right field and aaron judge is there
to end the inning after one and a half
no score in the bronx
strike one from houck who despite his
record of owen iii has an era under
three
hit toward left center field it will
drop
in front of verdugo and the yankees have
two on with one out
tyler wade is on deck
and sanchez hits it hard but right at
devers and the runners scamper back
so now with two on and two out it's up
to tyler wade
hard hit and through
here comes boyd around third and they're
gonna stop him
phil nevin stops it
and the yankees have the bases loaded
with two out so a chance for andrew
velasquez who has a yankee is two for
16.
hits it hard to center field
it'll score two velasquez comes through
and the yankees take a two nothing lead
with that base hit he nearly equaled his
prior career rbi total like most yogi
isms or all of them there's wisdom
embedded in there totally
spanked into center field for a base hit
by the lunge of velasquez
and dalbeck is a board with one out
a little squibber montgomery is on it
they take the play at first runners are
second and third now with two down
go back at third hernandez at second and
the o2 pitch to bogarts
line to left could tie the game one is
in
here comes hernandez digging for the
plate
he scores they may get the third out at
first and they do
as bogarts found himself in no man's
land but he drives home two to tie the
game awareness court awareness on the
diamond and tom goodwin is yelling at
him get back
judge strikes out
how happy is joey gallo
to exchange rangers tags for pinstripes
especially since he was a huge yankee
fan growing up
very happy to be here
a high fly ball to right
martinez started back now comes in and
he takes it and the yankees go quietly
in the bottom of the third
and then as renfro tried to move from
first to third
the yankees threw him out
a high pop and i do mean high on the
infield sanchez off with the mask
generally you don't want him to make
this play
voigt arrives late and sanchez does make
the catch
wow
i thought devor should have been running
harder because of possibility to get to
second that is such a difficult play for
the catcher it shouldn't really not be
his ball martinez still trying to solve
montgomery who struck him out
and he gets him once again
changing speeds mixing it up
[Applause]
as schwarber strikes out he had played
only two regular season games didn't
play in the division series or the lcs
and then went seven for 17 in the world
series
for the cubs against the indians
it's a good problem to have but again we
i talked about gallo balancing out this
lineup it's even better when you've got
rizzo's left-handed bat in there as well
and voight strikes out
and now velasquez drives one into right
center field but renfro is there to run
it down
velasquez with another good swing the
yankees leave too bottom of the order
for the red sox vasquez verdugo and
dalbeck
vasquez sends a high fly ball deep left
field tyler wayne watches it leave the
yard
and the red sox grab the lead
just the fifth home run of the season
for vasquez but it's a big one
interesting seeing whitlock up i wonder
if cora will start the inning with him
3-2 pitch and dulbeck goes down swinging
that's six strikeouts for jordan
montgomery
and now it's boone walking to the mound
jordan could not execute it the end of
his day
so montgomery exits albert abreu will
enter hernandez takes off
and renfro lines one into right field
judges right there
the bases are loaded on three walks
a little looper into shallow center
field and it will drop
gardner scores judge scores and the
yankees have the lead
the yankees have retaken the lead on
three walks in a bloop and now the
yankees go to the bench for john carlos
stanton he takes a cut and rips it into
center field for a base hit
here comes the insurance run they were
looking for
and it's 5-3 new york one out bases
remain loaded and [ __ ] hernandez to the
plate and the 3-2 pitch
struck him out
loisica battled back from 3-0
to fan hernandez and bring the yankees
within one out
of a win in the first game of this
doubleheader
ball game
louisika wants a tight rope in the
game's final inning but makes it across
from one end to the other